So let me just start with,
um,
father,
and this is a really interesting image of foreigner in Japan.
We know their partners so much associated with,
um,
Oxford,
Mississippi.
Um,
but he actually a travel quite a bit.
under the sponsorship of the State Department.
He was there because he,
the State Department asked them to,
uh,
travel around and um,
to give talks.
Um,
and what's interesting about Faulkner in Japan,
um,
is that some of the most interesting things that he says about his own novels.
Um,
we're actually set when he was in Japan,
um,
in the course of the [inaudible] seminar,
1955.
Um,
and this is really what he's asked about.
the sound of fury.
This is how the book grew.
That is,
I wrote the same story four times.
None of them were right,
but I had anguish so much that I could not throw any of it away and start over.
So I printed it in the four sections.
I mean,
there's obviously tongue in cheek.
He was saying that,
you know,
he's written so much in four different ways,
um,
that he can bear to get rid of any of it.
So in it's keeping all four and it's the same story told four times,
um,
tongue in cheek,
but there's an element of truth in it.
Um,
so,
uh,
less,
try out follow Faulkner in that thought.
Um,
and thing of the sound,
the fury,
the four sections of the sound and the fury as theme and variation.
Right.
So,
you know,
it was a very interesting musical structure,
theme and variation,
um,
basically is really the same story but told from four different points of view
using four different narrative techniques,
um,
and so producing different effects,
but really they are all rooted in the same phenomenon,
which makes sense.
It's really the same story.
Um,
and other way to think about this,
um,
and this is really a kind of adding on to,
have a sense that this is theme and variation,
um,
is the notion of kinship.
And this is really closer to our thematic understanding of the novel,
um,
that,
the three brothers,
each,
uh,
guests to tell his story in one section.
And then the fourth section is Toby.
Uh,
just an admonition,
uh,
narrators.
So,
but the first resections are two of other three concen brothers.
So there is a kinship among them.
Um,
and we'll think about,
uh,
the extend to which,
um,
they are brothers,
the kin in both a biological science,
uh,
but perhaps also in something,
in more than just a biological sense.
So,
um,
let me just lay out the three ways in which,
Benji and Quentin my be seen as kin.
Um,
and this is very much using the street analytic,
uh,
registers that we've been using all the way through.
Um,
the three analytics scales,
the largest scale to share macro history.
This is common sensical.
They live in the United States after the civil war,
so that is the common ground between them.
Um,
and in fact,
it doesn't take brothers to have that common ground.
Um,
and,
um,
especially thinking about race relations and the tomorrow of race,
thinking back to that line from my best in five f fives in five.
Um,
so that's the largest,
um,
you know,
ground for kinship between them.
Um,
and then there's another round for Kensho,
which has to do obviously with Walkman is narrative experimentation and the
traumatic loss of Cali that we saw last time.
This being repeated in the in section.
Uh,
likewise the incomplete syntax that is so striking and Benji will also be
repeated.
And Quentin.
Um,
and finally the important of the sense of smell of that is in Benji,
uh,
would also be repeated.
And Quentin,
uh,
we'll look at the kinship first and then we'll look at,
um,
uh,
variation.
You know,
even though they're brothers,
they're different as well.
So basically today's lecture is about kinship and variation,
but let's start with a kinship.
And I want to talk a little bit,
um,
about race after the civil war,
especially Faulkner's understanding of that.
So in is,
um,
not in 56 interview with the London Sunday Times.
Faulkner has this very interesting thing to say.
And in the ro one come out on top because anything to do with race,
but because he has always gotten by without scope,
when they'd giving skull,
they use it fully.
They are trained to do more than a white men can do with the same limitations.
So
this will be fine.
this is,
the,
um,
the way that I'll be like,
the thing about race is by going back to minutes Beth,
since five f five,
scene five.
And um,
the first line Ashley after Beth,
um,
[inaudible] I've seen five is tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow.
Um,
and thinking that mapping that onto raised relations,
uh,
we see that,
Benji's 33 years or,
um,
what kinds of future does he have?
Um,
and what kind of future,
um,
do the other black characters have.
Uh,
so let's look at Benji first and thinking about what future,
what tomorrow holds for Benjamin.
And um,
this is very early on,
the opening of the Benji section.
Listen at you now.
Lust to set into something there in three years or going on that way after I'd
done when all the way to town to buy you that cake,
hush up that morning.
Integral in to help me find that quarter.
So I can go to the show tonight.
Um,
Benji can talk obviously.
so luster is the one who was doing all the talking.
Um,
but I think the Faulkner's seems almost to the emphasizing that luster is the
player in the present and he's going to be the player in the future.
And everything that has been done by Benji is being done by luster and doc to
some extent the two black characters.
It's mother isn't doing anything for him.
Quentin,
the stead Kelly is gone.
Um,
so,
um,
luster is Benji's only significant other at this point.
Um,
and if for no other reason,
um,
the future belongs Benji to the extent that Benji could have a future and their
future can come only from luster.
So it's a really interesting way to think about the future of as being raised,
mediated and raised.
Dependent.
Ng is completely helpless,
overly luster,
can give him the future.
Um,
and lost is doing that.
all the things that catty used to do lustre is doing.
Um,
he's telling Benji to hush.
He's gone all the way to town to buy a birthday cake for Benji because Benji is
33 that day.
Um,
and so in that sense,
he's a very good,
significant other to Benji,
but more than that we see that lasted Ashley has alive apart from Benji.
The last sentence of that passage,
Angel going to help me find a quarter so I can go to the show tonight.
Um,
less than wants to go to the show completely independent of Benji.
he has his own desires.
He has a life,
um,
apart from Benjy and Benjy is really just an Osi as appendage and this case,
someone who should help them to find that quarter so we can go to the shop,
pay for the show and go to a show.
Um,
so all of this is to suggest that the playing field has been re configurated.
and who is at the center,
who is the main play?
Who's the protagonist in this drama that is unfolding into the future?
That really is an open question and this is a strong suggestion that the playing
field has been so reconstituted that black heritage would be the protagonists.
Um,
so let's,
um,
think more about the tomorrow of race.
Um,
but in this going off in a slightly different direction and this is the very,
and towards the very end of the Benji session book.
So basically we are looking at the two moments that bracket the Benji section.
Once again,
Benji is with his significant other luster.
He put my gown on,
I hush and then to stop his head to what?
The window that he went to the window and look out.
He came back and took my arm.
Here she come.
He said,
be quiet now.
We went to the window and looked out.
It came out over Quentin's window and climbed across into the tree.
We wash the tree shaking,
the shaking,
went down the tree.
Then it came out and we watched it go across the grass.
Then we couldn't see it.
Come on,
Lester said they are now hear them horns.
You get in that bed where my foot's behaves okay is completely ungrammatical and
that's just fine.
Um,
the future can belong to people who don't speak standard English is not a
problem.
Uh,
but what is interesting here is that we're seeing something that only one person
understands.
We are actually in exactly the same position as Benji.
We have no idea what's going on.
Um,
the meaning of what they're watching,
whatever it is,
they've coming out of Quentin's window and this is the female went and the
daughter of Catty,
um,
whatever's happening,
whatever's coming out of [inaudible] window was going to come after that.
What occasions that movement,
that window,
all this will not be disclosed to us until section three when we get to the
Jason Section.
Um,
so this was really interesting digital wrench or of knowledge in this moment.
Benji obviously doesn't know what's going on.
We,
the readers also don't know what's going on.
The only person who is fully in command of the requisite knowledge is last year.
Um,
I think that this is very deliberately set up by far,
um,
to highlight the extent to which black characters have knowledge in agency.
Um,
so,
um,
so much for Benji and obviously Benji is a part,
you know,
of the black world.
Um,
I think that,
you know,
we maybe we should even suspend,
I mean Benji looks white,
he's pleased,
he actually,
um,
but we can think of him as really part and parcel of the black world and his
wellbeing is completely dependent and offer piece with the wellbeing of the
black wall.
Um,
but that is not the case with Quentin,
although Clinton also has very important,
uh,
non trivial relations,
two black characters.
Um,
and one black character who was following him around is the Deacon,
right?
So this is a black man in Massachusetts.
Um,
and this is what the Deacon says to Quentin.
Yes sir.
Right.
This way,
young master here way is taking your bags from then on until he had you
completely subjugated.
He was always in and out of your room,
ubiquitous and gorillas.
There was manner gradually move northward as his Raymond improve until at last
when they had bled you until you began to learn better and it was called you
Quinten.
Um,
so this is a black man who is definitely not the same as the lusters [inaudible]
who have stayed on in Mississippi.
This is a black man who has moved north and here is important to um,
have some sense of the historical background,
um,
that Faulkner is alluding to.
A black man going north.
This turns out to be one of the key at Osos in African American history,
which is the great migration if that happens in several ways.
What we are seeing here is the first wave of the great migration.
Uh,
from 19 around roughly from 1910 to 1930 2 million African Americans went out to
south to the north,
to the Midwest and West.
Um,
and here's one image of the great migration.
The train station almost completely filled with,
uh,
blacks.
And um,
here's the wonderful painting by the pain of Jacob Lawrence.
Um,
if you are in these,
the make sure to go to the Philips collection,
um,
is a,
is a really interesting collection.
It's just a private collection that great paintings.
Um,
and they have the Jacob Lawrence are the great migration series,
um,
almost 50 or 40 or 50 drawings.
So it's really a wonderful thing that they have.
And so check this out when,
when you're in Washington DC.
Um,
so as you can see,
um,
the people are going to Chicago and New York and Saint Louis,
but some of them also ended up in Boston as it uses and the Deacon ended up in
Boston,
Massachusetts.
Um,
and once again,
you know,
he starts out sounding,
uh,
not only black but um,
southern black,
um,
calling Quentin young master.
Uh,
but then you know,
you actually in the course of one conversation,
he can actually metaphorically,
uh,
move north just in this space of that one conversation.
So,
um,
here is um,
something else that happens between uh,
Quenton and the Deacon.
Um,
and this is actually very obviously a,
a backward illusion.
Took my bath of five in five.
Um,
cause the word tomorrow is just a repeated about eight times in this little
passage.
Um,
this is something that happens,
um,
that when Clinton is thinking about his future and this will know that he has no
future.
Right.
Um,
so this is someone with no future talking to someone with a future.
Take this around to my room tomorrow and give it to Shreve who have something
for you.
But Nadia tomorrow my,
he told the leather and examined it is still down.
Yes.
And it's written within.
Not good until tomorrow.
My,
he was looking at me now to envelope weight in his black hand in the sign.
His eyes were soft and I restless and Brown and suddenly I saw Roscoe's is
watching me from behind all his wife folks clap trap of uniforms and politics
and Harvard man are deferred and secret in articulate and sad.
Wayne playing a joke on the old Negro as you,
you know,
I'm not,
did any southern ever play a joke on you?
You're right.
They find the folks that you can live with them.
Did you ever try as that?
The rascals was gone once more.
He was that self.
He had long since taught himself to where in the world's eye.
Pompousness spurious and quite not quite gross.
I'll confirm to your wishes.
My boy.
None until tomorrow.
Remember.
So the leather's not going to be delivered to shri until Quentin is no more.
Um,
and
the Deacon obviously will still be there and to reap the benefit of delivering
that ladder.
What is interesting here is the fairly compressed time,
um,
time scale that is pat into this low exchange in the course of one conversation
that you can,
can slide back into someone just like Ross,
cause I'm still in Mississippi.
Um,
from some time back,
uh,
with the manner and the diffidence and the fear really,
and uh,
lack of self assurance.
Um,
from some time pass he can slip back into it,
but his secure enough in the present,
in the presence in Boston,
Massachusetts that he can get out of.
And just also in that space of one conversation and it is not.
So the great migration is not just geographical migration,
but also psychological migration as well.
Um,
that in his own mind,
the deacon can move very,
very fast from the south to the north.
Um,
and that agility of movement is partly what gives him a future.
And there's nothing else about the sort of slightly ungrammatical are not quite
perfect command of English.
Um,
I'll confer to your wishes.
He means to say I'll defer to your wishes.
Um,
but actually confer is the Mo is a more appropriate word because he's not
actually deferring to Quentin any more.
Deference is a thing of the past,
a thing of the geographical self.
And because he's in Massachusetts,
um,
he's actually conferring something.
It is up to him to be the Asian and to confer something on Quanton.
So the recomposition of the playing field,
this dramatize in some sense through that into perfect command of the English
language.
Um,
and so in this sense,
this Faulkner is also a rewriting,
um,
both the future of rays but also the future of the history of the United States.
Um,
so in,
in both this ways,
Benji and Quentin a really can they have a lot in common,
um,
in the varying facts,
uh,
relations to black Harrison learners.
Um,
and then other very,
um,
just the thing that is something that you already know,
but I just want to refresh your memory.
Um,
they also,
uh,
can,
um,
in the very traumatic reaction to this loss of innocence on caddies part.
So this is something that we looked at last time.
Uh,
Benji,
uh,
the moment when Katty can no longer go to the bathroom and wash yourself clean.
We were in the hall,
caddy was still looking at me.
Her hand was against the mouth and I saw her eyes and I'd cry.
We went up the stairs,
she stopped again against a wall looking at me and I cry.
And she went on and I came on crying and she just ran against the wall looking
at me.
She opened the door to the room,
but I pulled at her dress and we went into the bathroom and she stood against
the door looking at me that she put her arm across her face.
And I pushed her cry.
So we remember this very well,
um,
moment when suddenly teddy is not putting her arms around Benji but across it on
face.
And it is,
I'm telling that it is almost completely reproduced.
Some repeated in Quentin section.
One minute she was standing in the door,
the next minute she was,
he was pulling on her dress and bellowing his voice hammered back and forth
between the wars in ways and choose shrinking against the war,
getting smaller and smaller with a white face.
Her eyes like thumbs that into it until he pushed her out of the room.
His voice hammering back and forth as though it's all momentum would not let us
stop as though there were no place for it in silence.
Bellowing,
um,
is exactly the same episode except that now all of a sudden we hear that sound
that bad.
The way they Benji is making them of course,
is invisible and in all level,
when Benji is telling the story,
we always gladly what that sound is doing.
Um,
Kelly seems to be a shrunken.
She's getting smaller and smaller as you are so pushed around by Benji.
Um,
there's just getting smaller and smaller until she was no place to go.
and we really haven't thought of Benji as being aggressive,
but that's really what he is,
you know,
innocence is aggressive and is the man that the world should completely conform
to his dictates.
And Benji is,
we learned this in demanding that catty should conform to his tapes.
Um,
and the balancing is the weapon that he uses to make sure that she does that and
when she cannot,
um,
he just keeps on doing that.
Um,
so we from Quentin,
we have this added perspective of what Benji is doing to patty.
Um,
but otherwise it's exactly the same moment that same candidate occupied the
emotional center.
Um,
and it's an unbearable please for the her two brothers to be,
um,
it's not surprising then that the consequence of that traumatic loss should be
articulated in the same way in Benji.
There's articulated as incomplete syntax and the consequences of that in
complete sentence.
I was trying to say and I caught her trying to say as your screen that I was
trying to say and the Australian can,
I would come after that.
Um,
he is Quentin,
um,
exhibiting the same symptom,
uh,
the same reaction to the laws of,
of catty.
And it is surprising because,
you know,
we can say that,
uh,
Manju has an incomplete syntax because he's an idiot.
He's clinically a retarding.
Quentin is not retarded.
Um,
but he also doesn't speak in complete sentences when he's very agitated because
women so delicate,
so mysterious fathers,
that delicate equilibrium of periodic filled between the two worlds balance
moons,
he said four and yellow as hard as wounds,
the hips,
eyes,
Lci,
Lci with them always,
but yellow feed.
So it was with walking in like the,
no,
that's on their,
that are those mysterious and imperious concealed with ardor inside of their own
shapes.
And our suavity waiting for a touch to liquid putrefaction like drums and things
floating like Powell,
rubber,
flowery filled,
getting the order of honeysuckle all mixed up.
It really is stream of consciousness,
um,
is completely internal to Quentin.
Um,
and the logic of association is also the cure,
Linda random.
So it would be very hard for us to understand completely.
All we can say is that this is both a point of commonality between Quentin and
Benji and also the pine point of departure or deviation from Benji.
We never get the sense that women are filled there,
um,
that there's something really repulsive and abominable about women,
that just having,
uh,
the menstrual cycle that in itself is kind of filtering.
Um,
and,
but this is really what Quentin is fixated on is this,
um,
kind of revulsion,
uh,
by female sexuality in this most elemental form,
um,
in the sense that it doesn't really take any action just in a state as female is
the sun,
something repulsive about them.
Um,
so this is,
um,
we,
this stream of consciousness,
um,
is farmer's way of getting us to get into your mind and is very different in
some sense as different from us as Benji's mine ears.
Um,
and so let's,
um,
think about,
also,
uh,
by way of the one thread that Faulkner is giving us.
Uh,
in the case of Benji,
uh,
we see that the guy,
um,
that is taking us through the various,
uh,
salient moments in band Bangi is the phrase catty smell like trees.
And in the case of Quentin,
the phrase that will perform a comparable function is getting the older of
honeysuckle or mixed up,
right.
We see that,
that's the last sentence in that,
um,
various strange passage.
Um,
and that phrase would appear again and again in the same manner as catty smelled
like trees.
Um,
so let's use that as a way to try to understand Quentin.
I don't think that we have a will to really,
uh,
and that Molly is a good thing.
That's really what fuck no best effect.
The farmer wants to collaborate.
Um,
and this is so this is moving away from kinship to thinking about variation,
the ways in which Quenten is different from Benji.
And one way in which Quentin is different from Benji is that sister is basically
very,
very clear,
very straightforward.
You live vocal meaning for Vanji,
it only has one meaning caddies smell like trees.
Um,
she's the source of everything that is wonderful and comforting and good for
Benji.
Um,
sister there were sister has a much more complicated meaning for Quentin,
so we can think of it instead of just as one word,
as a very calm,
relaxed semantic feel.
And,
uh,
well I like to do today is to follow the trajectory of that were sister and the
phrase honeysuckle all mixed up.
Um,
follow that,
um,
to try to get us from the beginning of Quentin's chapter,
but not quite as linear as,
um,
as I would like.
But I was trying to get us from the beginning,
uh,
Quentin section to the end of Quentin's section.
And I think that we all know that he killed himself,
right?
Kills himself by jumping into the Charles River in Cambridge.
Um,
and so how does he get from is just one day to space with that one day?
How does he get from the beginning of that day,
that morning to the end of that day?
And we'll begin at a point when Quentin is closest to Benji and then the way
other ways in which he gradually moves away from [inaudible].
But this is a Lowman,
uh,
when we certain know why it is,
we've learning more about why it is that uh,
Kelly's laws of sexuality is so traumatic to Quentin catty you them don't you to
move my hand up against her throat.
Ohad was hammering their pool.
Quentin who face,
look at the sky,
it was low,
so low that all smells and sounds and I seem to have been crowded down like
under a slap tend especially the honeysuckle.
And I got into my breathing.
It was on her face and throat like pain.
I had to pan to get any air at all.
Oh there they gray honey cycle.
Yes.
I hate him.
I would die for him.
I've already dive.
I dive in over and over again every time.
Discos
and
it's a weird moment.
Kelly is the one who is going to be pregnant because I've got this out of
wedlock or fear,
um,
with men.
Um,
and with someone that really,
she doesn't even know who the father is.
Um,
so she's the last person to be in a position to say poor Quentin.
but farmers understanding of the situation is that even though caddy is in the,
sorry,
isn't a dire situation at this moment and it's a much worse thing back in the
20s,
um,
for young lady to be president of Red Long.
Um,
but in spite of that dire situation,
Kelly still has a better life than Quentin.
Um,
and it has to do with the complete incomprehension of Quentin four caddies
lives.
So in lesson two we can say this is the common ground between Benji and Quentin.
Benji doesn't understand quantitative,
sorry,
Benji between bedroom kind of just doesn't understand if,
because he's doesn't have the mental capacity for it.
And Quentin doesn't understand Kelly because he's never had that experience and
we know about it.
And the session to the,
he never will have that experience was it,
what does it mean to have that particular sensation and to have gone through
that even though the,
the consequences are terrible.
So we can see another way in which,
um,
there's actually a point of intersection between,
uh,
the sound of fury and the great Gatsby.
And there's really a lot in common between Quentin and Gaspe as well.
The intense desire for the love object to deny that she has any relation to
anyone other than yourself.
Right.
This is what in Nice Quentin and Gatsby Gatsby can stand thought that dosing
might've been in love with Tom.
Um,
at one point.
And,
um,
Clinton Kent's then the thought that cutting Lashley be in love just at that
moment was just having sex with this guy.
He can stand that thought.
Um,
and that in the ability to stand that dawn says something about a lack in
Quentin's life.
Um,
if he had had that experience,
he wouldn't have hated it so much.
He wouldn't have been so unbearable for him.
So that,
and Kennedy completely understands that.
So that's the background for that repeated phrase who went and,
um,
and so this is the point where,
with Benji and Quentin a really as one,
the two brothers are as one and now we begin to move away from that one of unity
between Benji and Clinton because we also know that in fact a caddy is very
fleeting presence.
And when in the acquaintance section,
um,
the person who was there a lot,
it's actually a little Italian girl.
Um,
so that's a very odd choice on thoughtless bought that for a good part of the
quanton section.
Quentin is actually walking around with a little Italian girl that he calls his
sister.
So this is,
we decided to get the different permutations of the worst sister in this very
complex semantic feel.
Hello sister.
She extended the fist.
It uncalled around and they go moist and dirty.
Moise do it rich into her flesh.
I handed the buns to logo,
the fingers closed about them,
Dan and hot,
but worms,
I went on,
then I look back,
she was behind me under my elbows sort of eating.
We went on,
it was quiet.
Holly.
Anyone about getting the order of honeysuckle or mixed,
she lived,
told me not to let me sit there on the steps.
Hearing the door,
twilight slamming,
hearing Benji still crying suburb.
She will have to come down and getting honeysuckle all mixed up in it.
So here we study together the conflation of the two sisters,
right?
So there's the,
the in the Italics is going back to that dramatic moments.
Still caddy not being able to wash yourself,
clean Benji bellowing doors,
slamming caddies threw up in her room.
So still that moment.
Um,
but that moment it's bleeding into that moment from the past is bleeding into
Quentin's current walk with the little Italian girl and that accounts for the
images of dirt and filled that that'd be improved.
Acted onto the boat.
Italian goes just as a little girl,
um,
you know,
getting punked.
Um,
but the images of her actually have a much older woman,
moisture and dirt rich into flash.
Um,
so at the very least we can say that Quinton's experience of the entire world is
channeled through,
mediated by and contaminated by his stance of the laws of sexual innocence.
On the pilot cavity so that every single woman that he's going to encounter is
going to carry some attributes of the candidate who is lost or sexual innocence.
Um,
and there was sister also carries the weight of that contamination.
but there are other interesting permutations afterwards,
sister.
Um,
and I just want to go back,
take us back now to the very opening of the Quentin section.
Um,
and this is,
um,
something that is once again very peculiar,
a kind of logical association,
not entirely clarify for us.
I don't suppose anybody ever to liberal label listen to watch or clock.
You don't have to.
You can be oblivious to the sound for long while then in the second of taking it
can create in the mind unbroken,
the long diminishing the rate of time.
You didn't hear,
like father said,
download long and lonely like race.
You might see Jesus walking like,
and the goose in France,
they said the little sister that the never had a sister,
um,
is making no sense to us on page 76 and it's probably still not making a whole
lot of sense to you right now.
Um,
we know though that,
uh,
the watch is very important.
He steps on a watch and bricks the face of the watch.
So He seems to have some quarrel with that watch.
And we'll come back to this implant detail at the end of the Quentin section.
Uh,
what is it?
Why is it that he's so angry at the watch?
But for now,
let's think about that last line.
And the good thing Francis,
they said little sister death than ever had assistance.
So we've just seen the mapping afterwards,
sister onto the Lelo Italian girl and now we're sister is mapped onto death.
Okay.
So what is it then enables that mapping to take place?
And here I should say something about,
um,
the way of reading.
Father on the whole,
I don't really think that we need to do a lot of research,
um,
to understand Fatima.
You know,
he's hard to understand,
but actually it takes more reading than,
than doing a lot of outside research.
But here is one moment when Ashley,
um,
some outside research with castle lite on this particular logic of association.
So,
um,
I just want to bring up this very strange,
uh,
passable,
reference for Forkner.
Um,
and that is,
um,
it has to do with Saint Francis.
And he's telling us that Saint Francis is important to him for some reason.
Um,
this is the Saint Francis Canticle of the sun,
which turns out to be pivoted on the word sister.
Praise being my Lord for system,
Moon and for the stars.
Praise me,
my law for system water who is very serviceable and to us and humble and
pressures and clean,
praise me,
my Lord,
for our sister and the death of the body from whom no man living can escape.
So,
at the very least we can say that those different mappings that we're seeing in
Quentin seem to bear a very close charisma handlers to this particular logic of
association from,
um,
that we see in Saint Francis.
Um,
honestly,
you know,
even though the two logics are similar,
it's for a different reason that Quentin would have that kind of clustering of
terms.
So let's move on now to see what sister water means for Quentin.
Um,
and this is once again going back to caddy,
but suddenly water is coming into play.
Um,
in his relation to caddy gotten married.
Somebody,
have they been very many caddy?
I don't know too many.
You look after Benji and father,
you don't know who it is then does he know?
Don't touch me.
When you look after the NGN fodder,
I began to feel the water because I came before I came to the bridge.
The bridge was a grazed on mission that was slow moisture with a fungus crab
been even the water was clear and still in the shadow whispering and clucking
about a stone in fading swirls of Spinning Sky Kelly that I've gotten to marry
somebody.
So the most obvious,
clearest back is that Kelly is pregnant and then she needs to marry somebody
energies about America's somebody.
Right?
So this is about the only thing we know.
Uh,
but what is interesting here is that when she's about to get the married and
will be,
if the consen house was [inaudible] to Quentin is where you look after Benji and
father.
It is something that someone who's about to leave for say someone who was about
to get married and leave was that,
but it could also be sad by someone who's about to kill herself.
Right.
You know,
I'm going to be gone.
The two hospital meetings for look after father and Benji,
someone who's no longer going to be over around anymore and it's by someone
who's not going to be a rush in the two different ways in which catty could be
not around anymore.
Right now she's going,
going to do the marriage option best the way in which is not going to be around
anymore.
But in Quentin's mind there's already that [inaudible] rude that he's toying
with.
It would be very nice if caddy were to kill herself by drowning himself.
It would be one way.
It would be the water.
This time is not something in the bathroom.
It would be this gigantic body of water,
but she was indeed wash yourself clean in that body of water.
So this is one way in which sister and water constitute a potential mapping in
Quentin's mind.
But Kathy is not going to do it.
She's just going to get married.
It's just going to be alive.
So
this is the problem for Quentin is that Kelly is not going to clean herself by
killing herself,
by jumping into the water.
Um,
and he's furious and the world is not.
Nothing is right when she refuses to clean herself as he demands her to be
clean.
So this is his conversation with his father and father said is because you are
version,
don't you see women on their versions period.
Here is the negative state and therefore are contrary to nature is nature is
hurting you,
not catty.
And I said,
that's just worse.
And he said,
so his virginity and I said,
you don't know.
You can't know.
And he said yes on the instance when we came to realize that tragedy is second
hand.
So it would have been the right kind of tragic rating.
If caddy had just killed herself by jumping into the water,
it would have been appropriate cleansing kind of tragedy.
And is that she's not killing herself.
Somebody has to kill himself,
uh,
you know,
to,
uh,
perform that needed action.
Um,
and Quentin's father is completely,
um,
disapproving and in fact,
uh,
making fun of that whole operation.
Um,
that is right.
The caddies shouldn't be too upset about her pregnancy.
Women who never version to begin with,
never,
they never versions interesting interpretation of virginity.
Um,
but I think that it really is,
uh,
an interesting,
um,
observation,
that the person who is both on the part of Mr. Thompson but also in the policy
softener,
um,
the,
the person who ought to be most upset by all of this is actually not the most
upset of valley.
Um,
and what happens when tragedy becomes second hand comes by Terry tragedy.
Quentin is reacting to this tragedy on the part of his sister and making it his
own tragedy because in some sense,
that's really the only thing that he can call his own.
So the problem with secondhand tragedy is that it really is somebody else's
tragedy.
It is not Quinton's on tragedy at the moment.
He's been devastated by it and he likes to be devastated and who likes to be
heroic and devastated and to be devastated on behalf of his sister and to feel
that,
that he's the one who's going to make everything right.
Um,
but there's always the danger that a second hand tragedy will very soon fade out
and become a non tragedy.
And that's why the word temporary is such an unbearable for Quentin to
contemplate and I temporary and he Mr. Thompson,
his father and he,
you cannot bear to think that someday it will no longer hurt you like this now
and I temporary and he it is hot.
Believing to thing that I love or sorrow is a bond purchase without design and
Wishman tours willy nilly and as recall without wanting to be replace by
whatever issue the gods happened to be floating at the moment and I temporary
and he was the sad as word of law.
There is nothing else in the world is not despair until time is not even time
until it was so the tragedy isn't even that caddy is pregnant.
That's really nothing.
The tragedy is that the fact that Quentin is devastated now that wouldn't keep
forever,
is going to,
he's going to lose.
He won't be able to hold on forever to that sense of devastation and that is the
tragedy that he's going to find to put them and to claim once and for all by
doing what he does at the end of the novel.
And this is where he jumped off.
Um,
from that,
this is the bridge that he jumped off from,
um,
in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
And it just so happens that it seems that some breathers reader had gone there,
you know,
sprayers because of the spelling of the word older.
Um,
but at that bridge is actually a plaque saying Quentin Thompson drown in the
older of honeysuckle one to 1910.
So this is a very,
very good reader of fog and knowing exactly when is central infarct as mine.